do you know how many states make up the
USA
53.
yes do you know how many stars are on
the flag
52. okay it's close enough I got it you
can't I just I I started stammering I
have to think that some of these people
are just joking that's basically like a
96 you know he's a couple percent off
what are you gonna do Joe who is on the
one dollar bill
no who do you think is guess
Abraham Lincoln do you know what state
Missouri is in
no if you had to guess what state does
it sound like it's in
that should sound like it's in London
this is an American
crazy man yes what year will it be in
eight years
yes do you know what year it was 100
years ago
bro you might give me all now uh bro
around what year like if we had to guess
no I'm done come on bro let's go with
19 oh 1900s is that close enough well in
19 what 19.
05. is it close enough yes all right so
the the the immediate response is these
people are dumb as bricks but they're
they're not
um are they not they're not naturally
inclined to Jordan Peterson levels of
intellectual achievement but this is an
education system problem this is a
societal problem these are very basic
questions that half-wits can be taught
to answer correctly yeah but you have to
this that's the thing like you don't
teach people what was 90 years ago what
was 100 years ago you teach them to
think and then you can like all right
it's 2023. minus a hundred what's 2023
minus 100 like it's not [__] rocket
science here you don't got to teach them
but but you do people need to be taught
how to think not just what to think well
that's what you think and this this this
disgusting thing we've done in the us
where we just dumb everything down so
that everybody passes and feels good
about themselves but never actually
achieves anything in their life because
they're freaking morons because they got
pushed through a lame system you know
yeah and then they can spend the rest of
their lives feeling bad about themselves
because you don't want to hurt their
feelings when they were nine all right
all right my God no it's infuriating
look what's happening to our country
it's a couple of [__] no it's a
lot of them it's a lot of [__]
it's a lot of [__] that don't
know what they're doing do you know how
many states make up the USA
I think 50 or 51 because I don't know if
they count Hawaii as a state 350 I'm
gonna go with 50. do you know what year
I wasn't even the dumbest one but you
know the 12 Olympics were held
2012 Olympics yeah do you remember what
year that was that happened
so what year was the 2012 Olympics held
yeah like what year were they held I
think they were in Tokyo
remember what year
what's going on in his brain so like
you're asked a question and your
synapses they're firing your neurons
they're communicating and they're like
okay 2012 Olympics what context do we
have here to guess what year the
Olympics were that he's asking me so you
you analyze you're like 2012 Olympics
you're like you know the word Olympics
doesn't help me answer maybe the first
thing he said will give me the answer
right this is just like sometimes even a
smart person can be you know like you
can be tricked into a silly question
being hard but you know after one or two
questions your brain's a little warmed
up this isn't even I mean this this
young man was asked a series of
questions even if this was the first one
this is pretty sad maybe he's just super
baked you know you never know but that
is another societal problem that people
just walking around out in public all
wasted God bless you please cover your
face turning turning your face away is
not polite enough I never watched that
[__] but it sounded like it was around
like probably around you though
2000s
probably 19 1999 one of those one of the
things that I've learned a lot about in
the past couple years is discipline get
control of your head control your mind
and learn discipline and so you stop
talking yourself out of things and so
you know Tom Shea the Navy SEAL who we
work with I went through his 21 day
challenge where he gave me some tasks to
do every day and part of the challenge
was to wake up every day commit to doing
it and every time I started to talk
myself out of it I would have an excuse
run through my head some lame ass excuse
and there are four main excuses that he
teaches people that are that ruin lives
that's why we're doing the 21 Day
Challenge again together which Sunny is
not excited about because he's going to
have Tom on his ass if you guys actually
would like to do that with us go to the
link in the description because there's
a discount code come and do it because
guaranteed in one area of your life
there's something you're not doing
because you talk yourself out of it
every day you can go to the top of the
description click the link and buy it
with code Sunny fast50 for a nice
discount and we'll be doing it with you
guys would be in the zoom calls and
everything it'll be cool if you get one
dollar every single day for an entire
year then how much money do you have at
the end
you got to do some math the uh I mean
like every month is not the same amount
wow I don't know like 1500
yes right you just guess that I guess
that's that's crazy if you make ten
thousand dollars a month and you work an
entire year how much money do you get
paid at the end
oh come on bro simple math bro
this isn't even like you just said it's
not even like the pound of cotton pound
of stone question where it's like meant
to trick you like this is literally
Point Blank like just use your brain
like how do you solve anything if you
can't answer this how do you think of
anything what thoughts do you have what
what do you think all day your brain is
awake 24 hours when you're sleeping
you're thinking what do you think 300K
yeah what country did America get their
independence from
you're asking me a [__] ton of History
questions I don't know friends
yes nice do you know what state Missouri
is in
it doesn't sound like
I don't know Missouri Missouri probably
gives me like Texas Vibes it's very easy
all right this guy's baked look at him
yeah this guy's so baked yeah wait yeah
I know he is wait I actually thought of
that bro
from him I don't even think I was
sitting down oh this guy looks toasted
right now he's chilling right now what
state is right under North Dakota
I don't know guess a state like if you
could picture the USA
give me your best guess
um North Dakota North Dakota North he
just said north
yeah
give me your best guess most educated
guess
Dave
Canada
yes yes yeah that's actually insane they
got that right what year was it yo
I'm done this depresses me so much you
know what it is you look at this and
you're like it's less competition out
there you know I look at all these bozos
I'm like yeah I don't got to worry about
you in business you're good I guess I
just I just
have stupid idealistic belief that all
human beings should have the opportunity
to reach their full potential but we put
our trust in the government who does not
give a flying [__] if we come out with a
half a brain because they were easier to
control when we're dumb and we're
excited about things like going to
Spencer's instead of achieving anything
or building a life and that I find
depressing
22 years ago
22 years ago 22. you around what year
you're making this one too complicated
brother that's that's a hard question
gotta do some mental math
2022.
but I have to give it to this 1986. look
at how nicely yeah he's only wearing
what year was it on jeans that boy but
he is like so clean his sneakers are
Sparkling White his shirt is like
pressed and this is what you take out of
this yes he is good at that he takes
pride in his appearance the hoes loved
it no and he's clean like like look at
like like you look at me I'm wearing a
college man in a nice sparkling pair of
white sneakers like he that means he's
taken some pride in himself you know but
this young man can't do basic math at
the same time so he is capable of doing
things well that's what bothers me um I
see your point yeah maybe he'll have to
give me some fashion tips should I start
rocking the hat like him I don't like
the way he's wearing his happiness you
know that's a fact he does good choice
yes nice what year was it 100 years ago
minus three joints right here minus 20
no no 19.
yes nice yeah around there do you know
who fought in the Mexican-American War
no I don't actually you don't remember
that one no if you had to guess two
countries like who fought against who
give me your best guesses countries
[Music]
can you repeat the question again though
the war it was called the
Mexican-American War do you remember who
followed who against who
I mean can I just guess like yeah give
me your best guess um guess two
countries two countries yo
Japan yes
Germany
yes dude no way you're just guessing
them that's actually insane you know
what state is right under North Dakota
come on buddy you got South Dakota too
easy
[Music]
there he goes [__] got that
wrong
guys go that is funny I'm sad that was
hilarious no it wasn't a good four
minute video it wasn't funny you didn't
enjoy that no it's disturbing that these
are the people that have to go interact
with out in the real world yeah when
you're like by when you're buying shoes
you go to that kid okay you'll be all
right we'll give you he might give you
the wrong change but you know just
double check thank you so much for
watching make sure to like subscribe
follow me on Instagram at sunnyfaz or
post a lot of cool stuff follow my mom
on Twitter so she stops bothering me
just tweet all day all right see ya
[Music]
gone